today in honor of july 4th independence
day i will be
defending america from the attacks
of salty tick-tockers this will be on my
part i think
uh perhaps not quite as brave as the
colonists fighting against
the british for independence but i think
not far behind i think it's like in that
realm
they'll build statues to me one day i'm
sure and then those statues will be torn
down
um it'll require almost as much valor
and daring you might say
now there are a lot of america haters
out there in the country as we know in
general
a great many people who are living here
and enjoying the luxuries
and and and the liberties and the fruits
of living here and who certainly would
not want to live anywhere else which is
why they're here
and yet they're resentful and they're
angry
and they can't quite explain why that's
the one thing they can't do or maybe
maybe they can or maybe they can explain
let's go to tick tock and
we'll give them a chance to present
their case such as it is
and uh we'll start with this hi
so i just texted my dad to ask about my
canadian citizenship
because my brother um applied for his
because apparently that's something that
i have
that i can do kind of cool but anyways i
just attested
uh to apply for mine because i didn't
have any interest in it like a couple
months ago but now i'm [ __ ] terrified
to live in this [ __ ] country because
i'm so
over it um because i hate my town and i
hate the country in general
and that's just on hating america
um not that my career can really
function in canada at
all so i don't really know what i'm
gonna do there um
i guess we would figure it out if it had
to happen but you know rather be
prepared
she will be sorely missed stop don't
come back what will this country do
without her so really she's on drugs
right isn't that the
the first clue is that she's moving to
canada and the second
is that she's babbling incoherently i
mean canada of uh why
what are you gonna do in canada become a
syrup farmer i don't know about it and
what i i just want to know
in what way nothing against canada i
just in what way is canada an
improvement what
what problems do you find here that you
won't find there
she has no answers for those questions
obviously all she knows is that she
hates it here
but i know what she really hates and
we'll and we'll circle
back around as jen vasaki would say uh
and we'll talk about that because
there's a common thread through all
these videos probably but let's uh let's
keep watching
if you're american and you think america
is the best country in the world can you
please give me a genuine reason why
i don't know how many times we've got to
tell y'all america is a third world
country in a gucci belt
we hate it here too like we don't want
to be here
a third world country uh he says
lounging on his bed
in what looks to be a shower cap
recording a video on his 900
phone which he'll upload using his
internet connection
and then spend the day scrolling the
internet playing video games
eating whatever snacks he finds in his
mom's pantry yeah a third world country
that's what this is you're comfortable
you're clearly well fed
healthy yeah you think you're in a third
world country
and all that speaks to is the extent of
your own comfort and your own luxury
you're so comfortable that like if your
mom runs out of cheetos
and and you have to wait 45 minutes for
her to get back from the store
suddenly you're suffering like a
starving child in ethiopia that's the
extent of your comfort
but maybe i'm not maybe i'm not being
fair i don't know because i i thought
i saw this and and uh like with all
these videos i think well maybe
is he he hates it here maybe this guy
has real complaints i don't know maybe
he's got real complaints about his life
and about this country
maybe he's really suffered in his life
maybe he's really deprived
i don't know so i went to his page just
to see what else i could find to figure
out what his saab story is
that would make him hate this country so
much and i think i found it here here it
is this is the same guy
you know here i was today walking out of
work
being a citizen of capitalism and
i come and find out somebody hit my
just hit the mirror and then ran away
ran away not only did they run away but
they took the mirror with them
you know how disrespectful you have to
be to not only hit so much
take it with them like you're
evil oh my god
i'm pissed i'm pissed i'm pissed
i'm pissed whoever took my mirror
well i retract my previous remarks i
mean this is a man
uh who has suffered i mean he's taking
the time
to make a video along with like putting
the words up on the screens we had to
edit this
and it's good they put the words on the
screen because because we got to make
sure that every
word that he says we don't want to miss
any of it it's so eloquent and important
the whole world had to know about this
complaining about someone hitting the
mirror on his car
shortly this is someone who has lived a
life of just untold misfortune
life is pain he has a reason to hate it
here i guess
and um and and since he does hate it
here let me let me just offer
him a suggestion and i would offer this
suggestion to
anyone else who who hates it here and
hates this country um
you can leave get out
leave the country there there is no law
i got good news for you
no law requiring you to stay
i wish there was a law requiring you to
leave but there isn't
so you can uh choose to stay or to leave
and that's a choice that you have why
would you stay in a place you hate
all right let's keep going and this by
the way these are all most of them on
under the hashtag
uh hate america or hate america 2021
there are a lot of videos on in that
theme on tick tock and here's another
[Applause]
one
hmm so he says while you're celebrating
your fourth of july don't forget whose
land you stole to celebrate your freedom
okay when you say the land that you
stole you're referring to white settlers
hundreds of years ago here's my my next
question
when they moved in and took land did
they steal from the tribe that occupied
that land at the time or from the tribe
that that tribe stole it from
or from the tribe that the tribe
that stole it from stole it from you see
because this entire continent was
was awash in conquest slavery murder war
long before anybody with white skin
showed up
these tribes all of them all of them
lived by the law of conquest if you want
it you take it
if you have it and you want to keep it
you defend it if you have it and you
want to keep it and you can't defend it
you lose it
does that make it right for white people
no but it doesn't
it's not right for anybody that's just
that's the way the world worked
so um the white man showed up and uh in
some cases they played by the same rules
they didn't invent them
to the white men who steals our land
and steals our sons to the white man
if a tribe gets moved off their land by
white people
are but they had just moved other people
off the land
who they they're thieves also so who's
the victim
i i never i could never quite get an
answer to that question
let's see we got uh we'll try one more
i'm still waiting for someone to present
some kind of uh
of articulate argument maybe this will
be it let's watch this
[Music]
okay that's edgy stuff there i mean the
guy's got the fingernails painted black
and everything
i remember when kids did that when i was
in middle school to prove how rebellious
they were
and we called them goths back then they
call them something else now but really
the word that
that binds them all together would be uh
dorks
dorks by another name real tough guy by
the way covering his face while he does
this
yeah but i think this brings us back to
the beginning i said i was going to
circle back and i'm going to
um all these people who hate america
what what do they really hate
and i'll tell you they hate themselves
that's what they actually hate they are
they are dissatisfied with who they are
and with their own lives and they've
projected those feelings of resentment
and uh and failure onto on to the entire
country
trump and the usa it's kind of a common
thing people do in fact in one form or
another
you know someone who's failing at life
might
pick up and move to another town or
another region or they go traveling
around the world or something
and they and they and they think that a
change in scenery will change
their life but it won't because it's the
the problems are internal there's an
internal source of their trouble
so it never works because wherever they
go
they bring themselves with them and the
self is really the problem
in this case with these people the self
should be the problem
they should be dissatisfied with
themselves because they are miserable
losers after all what they need to do
here's what i would recommend rather
than stewing and how much you hate
america when really you hate yourself
and thinking about it so much just get
out of your own head for a moment
stop thinking about yourself for five
seconds
crack a beer have a burger enjoy the day
july 4th and we'll end on well i don't
know a positive note for once
it does happen on occasion happy july
4th everyone
well thanks for watching the video
everybody and you know what if you
really love america you know how you can
prove that to me you can like
this video and subscribe and if you
don't you hate america so like
right now and subscribe do it now now